are you dating it all in quarantine have
you been on a date yeah yeah i've been
dating a lot i can
i can list off all of the girls i've
been dating let me see all right let's
go
well david hi hi how are you yeah we do
these interviews we just
zoom like once a month i know it's
really nice i was just napping
i was an epic about four minutes ago
that's why my voice is a little weird
but i think your voice sounds fantastic
thank you i'll take more naps
if you get hit by three balls
that pretty boy you're out well let's
talk about dodgeball thunderdome
premiering 19th how would you
i'm just curious how you would describe
this show so it's like classic dodgeball
but it's
uh there's a lot more twists and it's
like
it's like an amped up version of regular
dodgeball so
um you have you have contestants running
through an absolute course
and they have to try to get to the end
by getting
by getting hit by the least amount of
dodgeballs and by not
falling off or not having a horrible
time then everybody always falls no
matter
whether they're like big time athletes
or or their everyday people
everyone always always falls have you
done the course have you
tested them yeah so i didn't
i did once like it was like they were
trying to
i had to shoot something and i quickly
hopped on the course like just for fun
because
they were like setting up the cameras
and i just got really bored and i got
stuck in the middle of the little
balance beam and
it really like it it really convenes
inconvenienced everybody for like two
minutes
because at the bed the producers had to
come over and grab my hand
and walk me off the bounce because i
wouldn't move i was stuck like a cat in
a tree i was just like i can't
[Music]
so last time i talked to you i asked you
are you dating natalie
why do you guys always troll us and what
did i say
you said no we're not dating then she
came on camera
and she was like we're not dating no she
wishes
can we get a natalie reaction can we
flip the camera yeah now what do you
what do you say
she said absolutely not
again
and two days ago though you posted a
tick tock
and you made some jokes about yeah did
you see was me asking to hook up with
her we're not dating it was me asking i
was like
can we please and she said no so so you
want to hook up with her though
oh so you weren't trolling us
but i wasn't trolling you i think you
guys should be able to see through that
one
um no i mean it's yeah it's it's it's
just fun because
natalie and i are pretty grossed out by
each other
so it's kind of like a joke to us and
that we know that we never um
but yeah it's still fun that's literally
like what gives us the biggest laugh
all the comments about people wanting
you oh my god it's
not even that it's just like when like
natalie makes a comment about like
wanting to hook up with me or me making
a comment about her it's just like the
funniest thing because it's so
uncomfortable and so awkward and it's
like why are you saying that
are you dating it all in quarantine have
you been on a date yeah yeah i've been
dating a lot i can tell i can list off
all of the girls i've been dating let me
see all right let's go
um no i haven't i'm not i'm i i don't
know i don't know where to go for that
where do you go like to like i know
there's
i know there's dating apps bumble which
i love so dearly um
but um brand deal
yeah yeah i'm gonna get paid a lot for
this one um
but i don't know i i haven't been able
to find
is it mrs right does anybody ever say
that
does anybody ever say mrs right right
yeah i haven't been able to find out
right what
what are you looking for i mean a girl
yeah i'm still going to put you up
i thought you were in a relationship
what are you doing yes
um okay um
somebody who's confident i love my
assistant's looking at me like this
i told i told that if you can if you can
find me somebody that i like and i'm
dating for six months
um you get you get all the promotions in
the entire world
um okay no wait who am i looking for
yeah someone that's
oh someone that's self-aware that's like
the most important thing to me
like like i like like i don't need
somebody to be like a stand-up comic but
like
the coolest thing to me about a girl is
like when
or like any human when someone makes a
joke and the joke falls flat
and their weight to be able to climb out
of that like
joke falling flat is so important to me
and i know it's so specific
but it's like like that moment go that
moment to me he's like well okay
this person knows like how to read a
room and how to like
you know maneuver their way around a
room and i think that's that's the most
important part to me
that's a mrs right for you that's mrs
right yeah yeah
that was very oddly specific though but
i appreciate it
yeah yeah i think that's it he's megan
goes
he's had a lot of time to think about
that that was the first time i've really
put it
into words and articulated her properly
um but other than that
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna be on the
lookout for you
please oh my god yeah let me play cupid
for you
i'll be waiting
what is the craziest rumor that you've
ever heard
about yourself that that i was under
under six foot two i'm actually six foot
four and people don't know that
you're not six foot four i'm setting the
record straight for you
oh you can make it you can make that the
title of this video i am six foot four
some people like to say that i'm under
no the video is starting with yeah i can
count all the girls i've been dating on
my hands
i've been dating so many girls and
they're all here at the same time
no i don't know i i hear rumors every
day
that aren't true but i don't like i
don't like talking about them because i
don't like fueling any rumors
before i let you go uh the election is
coming up so without
disclosing any political information you
don't have to but just
the importance of voting
it's so important to go voting i think
why it's important to go vote
vote especially on behalf of me is
because
i cannot vote and um and there's a lot
of people like me
that are in this country that would love
to stay in this country that have
families in this country
and um and that have you know had their
entire lives here
um and they want to stay and they want
to stick around and go vote on behalf of
your
peers and your friends that can't vote
or maybe even aren't old enough to vote
yet or whatever it is
you know it's a cool opportunity to vote
it's it's nice that we get it to do it
and we don't live in live in a
dictatorship that would that would be
rough right megan
megan hates dictatorships so
um yeah i think what
oh yeah i i think i just i should say
that it's important that i'm daca that's
what i was trying to get at
and i can't vote so i would really
appreciate if people would go out and
vote
on my behalf um whatever it is it's
really nice to make a
contribution like that you're you're
helping out a lot more than you think
you are and you're being a part of
something a lot bigger than
yourself